it seems that more and more often we are
getting power outages whether it's from
storms and other natural disasters or
even just power grids being overloaded
from the rise of electricity use at the
same time electricity is getting more
and more expensive getting absolutely
ridiculous in some areas and looking
into the future it doesn't seem like
prices will be going down but instead
getting more expensive so people are
starting to take matters in their own
hands because they want to ensure that
they have electricity to be able to heat
their homes in the winter and to cool
their homes in the summer this is even
more important in places where it gets
dangerously cold not only to keep you
warm but also to keep your pipes from
freezing and in super hot places to keep
your house from turning into an oven
with that of course you want to be able
to cook do laundry and to power your
lights and electronics as some of you
know we bought an older house and have
been Remodeling and with that I made an
effort to change some of our appliances
to ones that are more reliable in these
kinds of situations and do things with
lack of power in mind now in previous
years people have turned to multiple
solutions for great resilience including
backup generators which work but have
many downsides including only being
useful in backup situations instead of
being able to save you money or even
make you money using solar and Battery
Solutions which I'll cover in just a bit
thankfully technology has been improving
quickly and we have had some major
Innovations in 2023 and you no longer
need to rely on only a generator that
burns various fuels and has to be ran 24
7 in order for your home to have power
putting out heat fumes and noise which
could be a noising for you and your
neighbors now they still have their uses
and they can actually supplement a
modern grid resilient solar system with
battery backup like the one I will be
covering today from Canadian Solar with
their really versatile and impressive
epcube system as you guys know over the
last couple of years I've been exploring
and Diving deeper into the world of
solar battery backup systems and being
able to be self-reliant and it's been
amazing to have a lot of flexibility for
simple things all the way up to backing
up my full home the epcube system is on
a whole other level though and the way
that it's been designed is very
impressive from its form factor power
reliability warranty and flexibility and
the cool thing is that in the United
States we have a 30 federal tax credit
for residential clean energy which
applies for solar and Battery Solutions
and starting in 2023 Standalone battery
installations also qualify for that
credit and some states and utility
companies also have additional
incentives so you can save a lot of
money now before I get into the details
be sure to use the link down in the
description below to get more info and
to get a quote now this is a battery
system designed with a focus on solar
but with other features built in the the
first thing I want to mention is that
some of the competitors mainly work with
new solar installations and are limited
when it comes to homes that already have
solar installed which a lot of homes do
and usually in these cases you are
really limited especially from reliable
companies but Canadian Solar is a
trusted name and solar for over two
decades now and to back that up this
system comes with not a one or two year
warranty which you see from some Brands
but a 10-year warranty which is
impressive and not only that but it has
a 6 000 cycle rating which is
mind-bogglingly high even compared to
the Tesla powerwall and end-phase IQ
battery which will Decay to 70 percent
within 10 years while the epcube is 80
percent so about 10 percent higher if
you do the math compared to Tesla's 13
kilowatt hour battery ebcube can save
about 2400 kilowatt hours in electricity
bills compared with the other products
in 10 10 years it also passed UL
9540a testing which is really important
the batteries that are used are the most
safe kind on the market using
lithium-ion phosphate technology which
means it is the safest and most reliable
with basically little to no thermal
Runway making it much better than most
competitors the epicube also has anema
4X enclosure rating so it can be
installed either indoors or outdoors and
could withstand all sorts of weather and
you don't have to worry about corrosion
dust or water and with that the
competition is way less flexible epcube
stands out by being a modular battery
where you can choose how many battery
packs and modules you get since they are
stackable and you can combine them so
you can fine tune just how many battery
packs works best for you and what is
really cool is that it comes with a
built-in hybrid inverter so you don't
need one separately and because it's all
integrated including the communication
cables and wires with the quick
connectors for stacking directly EB keep
can be installed by one person while
most other similar products require two
to three people to complete the
installation because of their much
heavier weight that saves on
installation time and space and that
means it saves you money now the base
amount comes with three modules giving
you 9.9 kilowatt hours of capacity which
is already a fairly good amount for
emergency backups with that you can
actually have up to six modules per unit
and they stack up so you can jump to
13.3 16.6 and up to 19.9 kilowatt hours
of capacity with each module now the
mind-blowing thing is that you can
install up to six EP Cube units in
parallel giving you a maximum capacity
of almost 120 kilowatt hours of battery
capacity which is hard to believe
especially with how good these look and
how slim they are mounted to your wall
they are only nine and a quarter inches
thick at the thickest point and at the
thinnest just six and a quarter inches
and as you saw the design is very
minimalistic so they actually look good
no matter where they are placed now as
far as power outages even with just a
single EP cube in the smallest capacity
available and without any solar putting
in power it will output 5 kilowatts of
power and with solar with the full sign
that goes up to 7.6 kilowatts and if you
have five modules in a single EP Cube
you can get a full 7.6 kilowatts without
any sun this means that epcube can still
allow you to use 5 ton air conditioning
or other high-powered electrical
appliances continuously when it is off
grid and of course as you add more
epcube units that power output increases
up to a massive 45.6 kilowatt output
which is really impressive now this
system is also designed to be able to be
connected to two EV Chargers as
expansion making it perfect for those
who will want to have electric cars
connected so you can have a ton of
capacity and power and the system has 2
24 7 monitoring to detect an outage and
seamlessly energize your home when the
grid goes down so everything runs
perfectly now when you have no issues
with the power you could still make use
of the system and save money or even
make money in a lot of places you have
different electrical rates Depending on
time of day so you can pull from the
system when prices are high and then
charge the system back when the sun is
out when the prices are low and
depending on your full setup and utility
company you could even sell back
electricity so don't think that this is
only useful for battery power backup and
to charge this up you have a ton of
flexibility of course it is designed to
be used with solar either with new
installations where epcube could take in
high power solar directly or for
existing solar owners which can have the
choice to integrate existing solar
inverters for easier management now this
part is very important because epcube
could take either AC or DC power making
it impressively flexible compared to the
competition in their hybrid inverter has
a maximum inverter CC efficiency of
93.93 with that you can also tie in a
generator to charge up the system if you
need to you also have the epcube app
which you can open up and it gives you a
lot of different information right here
we are connected and we can see what is
coming into the epcube and what is
coming out so we're connected to grid we
also have a solar array there is no
generator or EV charger hooked up but
that is there and then we're having
power going to a non-backup load and we
also do have a backup load connected now
you can go in here and you can switch
from self-consumption mode backup mode
and time of use mode you also have other
settings here and you can even go in to
your settings and go and update the
system right from the app you have your
warranty information right here and you
can also get service right from the app
itself and they give you a ton of
different data with history right here
as well so you can really get into the
details so you guys can see that the app
is very powerful and very useful you
also have a smart Gateway which is
connected with Wi-Fi or cellular now the
epcube has three operation modes to
cover a variety of scenarios
self-consumption mode maximizes
utilization of green energy time of use
mode is best for users with time of use
utility rates like I spoke about
previously and backup mode for emergency
backup power scenarios so as you see
this system is very complete gives you a
ton of flexibility and is super high
quality with a great warranty if you
guys want to learn more and to get a
quote check out the link in the
description to Canadian solar's epcube
thank you guys for watching click above
to subscribe this is Max and I'll see
you in the next video